ils sont nombreux à avoir reçu la
première dose beaucoup moins la seconde
mais déjà il est question d'une
troisième dose de vaccin tiko vide
les américains parlent les britanniques
passent à la dès septembre on offrirait
un vaccin de rappel à tous les 50 ans et
plus ce qui efface xt 1200 une dose de
rappel c'est utile pour répondre à de
nouvelles menaces virales ou pour
renforcer le système immunitaire
affaibli la troisième dose on s'y
prépare surtout pour les personnes qui
sont qui serait sujette à l'exposition à
des variants comme qui réagir est moins
aux vaccins actuels ou à l'émergence de
nouveaux variants ou alors aussi la
troisième dose on en parle beaucoup pour
les personnes qui sont immuno supprimer
un rappel c'est également très utile
pour simuler un vaccin qui perd de son
efficacité avec le temps les vaccins
c'est ce qu'on souhaite d'avoir une
protection à long terme c'est ce qu'on
voit avec l'hépatite b
c'est ce qu'on voit avec le tétanos
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on souhaite
depuis le début de la pandémie les
laboratoires d'un excellent is évalue à
l'aveuglé les réponses immunitaires de
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
participent aux essais cliniques des
grands fabricants de vaccins certains
sont suivis depuis maintenant dizaine de
mois ce qu'on voit c'est que dalle tu
pour le même sujet il ya une descente de
la quantité d'anticorps qui mesuré dans
l'eau et c'est donc ça ça laisse
présager caprins certains tel le vaccin
ne se replient fkih âge ou du moins la
protection vont diminuer les compagnies
comme cez moderna et astrazeneca
travaille déjà sur la version 2.0 de
leurs produits et sur un calendrier de
vaccination
[Musique]
on évoque aussi scénario d'une
vaccination qui pourrait se répéter
année après année c'est un peu comme le
vaccin de la grippe
le vaccin de la grippe il ya les mêmes
choses qui se retrouvent à l'occasion
dans le vaccin
on sait que la la protection à long
terme n'existe pas donc on vaccine à ce
niveau là la bonne nouvelle les
fabricants tentent aussi de mettre au
point un vaccin qui permettrait aux
systèmes et mutin de reconnaître le
virus en tout 1
même lorsqu'ils changent d'identité dans
ces cas là peu importe le variant qu'on
a on aurait une immunité qui serait
assez universel contre même peut-être
contre d'autres coronavirus qui pourrait
émerger où les saisonniers ou le ce qui
circule dans le monde
ailleurs ça ça serait vraiment
extraordinaire ici norma grondin radio
canada montréal